we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p a very good
question and really more of a comment
raising an important issue about
conservatives and the military in
today's voicemail take a listen hi David
it's who callin from Idaho I love your
show you know that interview Trump did
with Hannity and throwing Biden's son
under the bus about his naval career
right and Trump avoiding the draft did
anyone else see the hypocrisy of that
that that just made me want to vomit so
keep up the good work
and I don't do Instagram or any of that
kind of social media so that's why I'm
calling you
and letting you know that that that that
hypocrisy needs to be brought out and
remind people he avoided the draft he's
got no business talking about anybody
else's military career yeah
listen there's actually there's too much
so okay hypocrisy number one is specific
to Trump which is Trump criticizes other
people and what they do or don't do with
regard to the military where Trump got
this letter signed by a doctor about his
bone spurs and his ankles a very strong
letter on the ankles is Donald Trump
once said who talks that way by the way
and it's bogus but I have to tell you I
would have done anything possible not to
be drafted to Vietnam it was a
ridiculous war it was a disaster and I
understand why people would try to get
out of it now for Trump it was he
wouldn't go to any war he was the rich
kid who wanted to doctors no and I
totally get that
but I actually don't really criticize
people for finding ways out of the
Vietnam War on principle that actually
makes sense to me although he is a
hypocrite
the real hypocrisy is that the right
frames itself as uber respectful and and
sort of honoring the military careers of
everybody except when it's people on the
left and and not even people on the left
even sometimes just people they disagree
with if you look at what they did to
John Kerry in 2004
what happened to respect for people who
served in the military instead attacking
John Kerry's participation in the
Vietnam War look at Trump going after
John McCain the late senator from
Arizona John McCain where he said
everything from I prefer war heroes who
don't get captured to who knows what
else
look at how they go after whoever right
that is the real hypocrisy that the
right claims to have a monopoly or the
moral high ground on respecting and
honoring the service of military members
when in reality it's only a tool - it's
a proxy to demonstrate their patriotism
but it disappears as soon as someone's
in the military that they don't like
whether it was Peapod a judge or whoever
it is that they want to criticize all of
a sudden the military service respect
goes out the window we've got a great
bonus show for you today two ways to get
access become a member or become a
patron I'll speak to you then